chris is in Rhode Island hi Chris
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how you doing better than I deserve
what's up basically has been a listener
for those months now it's been Iman ever
since and last month I was on baby steps
you
all right now the breakdown is I have
$300 left in a personal loan fifty four
hundred and student loans just shy of
ten thousand and credit cards thirteen
thousand left to my mom and I had a car
payment total or what I left owed on the
car was 19 thousand altogether it's
about 47,000 and basically had looked
into it and according to your system I
didn't need to get rid of my car is
right now among consumers about six
hundred sixty-five thousand this year
after taxes and so I looked into the
Kelly Kulick anyway so I was a
deconsecrated selling it and last week I
ended up rear-ending somebody in
totaling it
oh no okay yeah okay it was totally
there they were okay it was a girl and a
lipstick Jeep basically everybody was
okay but my car and my ego a little bit
but it ended up being a huge blessing
from God I have USAA and the settlement
that I agree to ended up being seventeen
thousand dollars cool yeah so it being
really good I'm just balanced because I
basically have the thousand dollars for
my emergency fund and the the issue I'm
looking at right now is right now for
work I have to travel it's either an
hour to an hour and a half back for Cape
Cod and basically what makes that worth
it is my company gives me about 88 to 92
dollars in non-taxed I they call it car
miles to go there now so how you been
good nurse I totaled a car so they told
us USAA gave me a free rental car for
how long I have to have it returned
tomorrow and so I mean just just as an
example here we just had a snowstorm and
on my way
with her health car a fishtail
thankfully I've never cover for my toes
there's no one here me I was driving
safely at the time too but I mean I've
been looking for an all-wheel drive or
four-wheel drive vehicle in that
thousand dollar range and basically the
other context is I have a bonus some
bonus that's owed to me
it's about after taxes it'll be about
eleven twelve hundred dollars and then
we also I have a $2.00 raised son since
the end of September and our contracts
had just gotten signed so I'll be
getting some retro pay altogether that's
like looking at like another seventeen
eighteen hundred dollars that will be
getting within the next like a couple
weeks so I'm really kind of stuck is
like I don't want to I mean I'm willing
to buy something in that lower thousand
dollar range although I can't find
anything that's like four-wheel drive or
all-wheel drive that looks like an
cleaned yeah I don't you talk dollar
rent-a-car and just rent your car for a
week or two that's so I think that's
looking like my immediate option like my
big question was it might might be
stopping my guests yeah we're stopping
everything you're in the middle of a
crisis okay so you're stopping
everything you're gonna use your
thousand dollars you're going to use the
1700 you're going to use any other thing
scrape out of the corner of the couch
you're gonna work like a crazy person
you're gonna look around see if you can
sell something on eBay or on Craigslist
we're gonna scrape together you know
maybe maybe you can get together three
four thousand dollars and get you a
little four wheel drive something right
perfect exactly what I was looking at to
take the minimum do so it looks like if
you can scrape then it sounds like you
can put that together in about two weeks
yep yeah yes I just don't want to buy
something that thousand dollar range I
don't I don't blame you and it's okay if
you have to but the good news is you've
got some other money coming we just got
to tap the brakes and you know make this
work right tap the brakes in this case
but yeah there's no problem yeah yeah so
yeah I think you've got I think you've
got your plan laid out I would just rent
the cheapest thing that'll get you back
and forth to Cape Cod for a little while
and you know in the meet with dollar or
rent-a-car and then they'd not worry
about the other driving the rental I'm
just up to you it's up to you the second
date second to third day oh just Fonda I
mean I'm not driving there so I don't
know but you figure that out but every
dollar you spend on the rental car is a
dollar you don't have to buy a car with
right yeah no we want that to be as
cheap as you can do right because it's
that's all we're buying here is a little
patience right yeah basically I just
wanna be foolish and not spend an extra
you know what maybe 40 eighty dollars
getting a older driver as a rental and
then wrecking it because do we have like
snow here and stuff well it's up to you
I mean I guess you could you got an hour
drive sober is probably out of the
question right yeah you work with
anybody that you could pay to take you
to work I know and how unfortunately
basically so I work for Peter Pan and
I'm the spear guy right now so when some
of them vacation I cover them but
otherwise I'm just driving up to the lot
and I'm basically hanging out alone
there so unfortunately like I'm in
between like the different shifts I did
look into because there's like a really
early bus that we had out from
Providence to like Hyannis and not born
near where I have to go but I mean you
can do almost anything except walk for
two weeks right that's all we got to do
here okay so the good news is this is
not a permanent solution it's not a
long-term solution we're just trying to
get to that $1700 check to put with this
and scrape together any other nickels we
can find stop everything
tighten your budget as tight as you can
do it don't spend any money on anything
and put it all in this car fun buy you a
car in two weeks and then restart your
baby steps with starting to fund your
thousand dollar baby step one again
perfect okay you can do it you are
almost there before you called me right
like I just couldn't get myself
transferred on the market for the you
know for that seventy eight thousand
dollars I'd lose and then this made it
worth it
yeah yep get her done man get her done
you can do it
there's always another day another day
to fight good for you